[Music]
the Winter Olympics start this week in
Sochi Russia that's gonna be happening
and gay now one of the biggest
controversies surrounding the game is
the Russian government's intolerance of
homosexuality last month the mayor
so she even said there were no gay
people in his town now I personally I
find it odd that there's so much
homophobia there especially when you
learn the names that Russians have for
the Olympic events for example in Russia
ski jumping is known as spreading your
legs and bending forward for glory
the two men lose translates to man going
down on another man what we call speed
skating is known in Russia as catch the
leaders but in Russia snowboarding is
known as straddling the wood and
swinging both way over there the
four-man bobsled is known as four
helmets in the same chute
pakhi roughly translates you guys
grabbing their sticks and pucking for 27
minutes without a timeout the term for
the women's slalom is cruising the mound
and avoiding the poles a cross-country
skiing is known as swishing and the
biathlon is known as swishing then
shooting your load and finally men's
figure skating is known as men's figures
[Applause]